11 joueurs contre 11 montés sur des
soclles sphériques les plus vieux
d'entre vous connaissent sans doute le
subutéo aujourd'hui toujours à la mode
le football de table a même ses
fédérations et ses grands tournois mais
on la fit accueiller le weekend dernier
l'un des grands schlem le major de Paris
mais le subuto qu'est-ce que c'est
l'attaquant su celui qui est en
possession du ballon doit toucher la
balle à chaque fois chaque fois qu'il
touche le défenseur va pouvoir faire ce
qu'on appelle un coup de défense pour
freiner la progression il fait ce qu'il
veut avec son coup de défense mais il a
le droit de rien toucher ni le ballon ni
un partenaire ni un adversaire
l'attaquant peut jouer vite si
l'attaquant ne touche pas le ballon et
donc le manque ou l'envoie à l'extérieur
ou sur un adversaire la possession
change demi-temps de 15 minutes avec des
prolongations au cas d'égalité un jeu
Mélan dynamisme technique et tactique
200 joueurs d'une quinzaine de nations
européennes et de toutes catégories
étaent rassemblé pour l'un des plus
importants tournois mondiaux vive Italia
vive la Belgique une foisin moi je suis
un pur pure pure attaquant
donc je suis une véritable trompette
avec mon gardien mais par contre en
attaque et un bon tireur 80 % qui se
passe dans la tête il y a 80 % de
technique il y a le sang frroid le
subutéo né dans les années 40 de
l'imagination de Peter adolp une coupe
d'Europe é créée desès 1964 un jeu pour
les 7 à 77 ans c'est un peu les jeux de
notre enfance à l'époque il y avait pas
de
console jouait au sousito on appelait ça
ce que j'aime bien c'est ben tout ce qui
tout ce qui se fait tactiquement le le
replacement je crois qu'après les jeunes
qui viennent sur mes stages et qui font
des des séances de de souousito on envie
de de s'amuser de de s'éclater la ville
de maison la fite pourrait accueillir
chaque année cette épreuve la France s
porté candidate pour être organisatrice
de la Coupe du Monde